in 1980 the US economy went into a
recession gautama beer production
dropped 37 and a half percent of Wall
Street reacted very badly but that
recession actually could have been
predicted if you were looking at a very
specific type of line you see normally
this line points slightly upward like
here in September 1977 but about a year
later it started pointing the other way
just slightly and then not long after
that boom
the 1980 recession it happened again a
few months later the line curve downward
then boom another recession it happened
again in 1988 again in 2000 and again in
the mid 2000s this line is called the
yield curve and it's predicted every
recession in the past half century and
that's why some experts freaked out when
this happened a recession warning
inverted yield curve an inverted yield
curve inverted yield curve so what the
hell is this line it all starts with the
US Treasury bond a bond is basically an
agreement saying if you lend the federal
government say $100 they'll pay you
interest while they hold onto your money
until the date they agreed to pay you
back and the longer you let the
government keep your money the higher
the interest rate so you get more money
next you need to understand that most
people don't buy bonds from the
government they buy and sell them from
each other in the secondary market and
the prices change based on how much
demand there is for a bond this
basically means that the amount of
profit you can make on each bond changes
every day still the basic rule holds if
you let the government keep your money
for longer you'll yield more money trace
these bars on any given day and you get
a curved line showing the yields of
different bonds or what people call the
yield curve and normally it points
upward now here's where things get more
complicated let's say you're an investor
and you have a hunch that an economic
downturn is coming in the near future if
your hunch is correct that means that if
you buy a two-year bond you might get
your money back in a bad economy and
there might not be anything good to
reinvest in that makes a two-year bond a
lot less attractive to you and if lots
of other people think this way then the
demand for 2-year bonds with limits so
they start selling for cheaper but
because the 2-year bond now cost less it
yields a better return relative to that
low cost and at the same time investors
who think a downturn is coming might
think I'd rather invest in a 10-year
bond that pays out way later when I
think the economic downturn will be over
so that bond gets more popular but it
also gets more expensive so investors
start yielding less money and if enough
investors are acting on this expectation
the yield on a long-term bond which is
almost always higher than a short-term
bond can actually dip lower and if you
drop that yield curve you can see that
it goes in the other direction it
inverts in other words when this chart
looks like this it means investors think
an economic downturn is probably coming
in the near future and that's what's
happening now
so is a recession coming not necessarily
but when we redesigned the chart so we
can see all the years on a single screen
it's pretty safe to say when the yield
curve inverts it's not a good sign
[Music]